I'm sorry guy said Brennan I just
talking about having we're talking book
talking books in history that's how we
are our role it's how we roll how was
the weekend my friend did some work did
some work he's doing a TV show I can't
really talk about right now long days
mine either way you're on set little
seven a.m. to midnight these days yeah
by the way hey careful what you wish for
they always say if you're gonna do a TV
show in Hollywood you better love it you
do I love it but you better love it and
when you do a one hour when you do a one
hour like let's just say si si it's not
a couple of one hour shows where at the
height of their fame like West Wing CSI
where you know everybody's watch them in
America and when you're sitting on that
set all day and you watch the stars who
have to come into a room and I mean and
I'm not joking when I say this well
you'll get there please you'll get there
at 5am maybe six you'll get some makeup
on then you wait around then what you'll
do is we got to get a shot of you coming
in and see in the back of the wall and
you notice something cuz you're a
detective so we have to have come you
guys come in you look at the back of the
wall and I want you to go huh and then
the other person is gonna go what and
we're going to cut but we're going to do
that about well we're going to dive for
three hours and here's why need a lot of
different angles a lot of different
angles and the lighting is always going
to [ __ ] up so it might take a look a
crime to have though but out but it is
i'm i'm guessing now he's yet to it
trust me i'd rather be doing this than
not get in the gig but also i'm not an
act this i'm not an acting as a host a
hostess i was thinking because i can't
give me any way i wish i could right now
obviously I'm for sure gonna spoil
nugget talk about it what are we doing
here I'm glad I'm glad keely and jay
road with us to the event Bolton like
grindin stop I'm like look in my life
dude I was talking the whole way two
hours did it stop talking once talked
hard talk fast rat attack about
everything rat-a-tat-tat random far like
a woodpecker on your room like a
woodpecker on your woodpecker that
[ __ ] stumbled in my cocaine stash and
just [ __ ] just went nuts thing though
when you said you talked a lot I was
like nah gonna up the ante I gotta gotta
talk you know you do that anyways it's
just what you do but I was glad they
could experience it I get pumped and
excited about their live shows what's
an older game in bryan callen sorry sir
i was just the kid just for older men
the kid did you listen to Rogen and Dan
blitz Syrian I did listen never
organized you know what we found very
interesting and all our followers you
start following damn now I sure did
that's insane after all it [ __ ] you
talked about you know what because I
listened to him I'm glad you brought
that up I listen to that podcast and I
came away with a really positive view of
dan Bilzerian I mean he seems like a
kind of a good guy at least he went to
buds twice I didn't know he's in the
military for four years he seems to be
an effective and good gambler I think
and he was very open about his challenge
now at 35 when he's ticked off the
bucket list of sensations he's
experienced because it's all sensation
five girls at once x 9 x just stand on
these are sensation that's his life
these are things that satisfy your
immediate urges well that's the normal
form now like it's not he like it
doesn't do it for so what happens as we
talk about what happens is you lose the
ability to stimulate once you have
satisfied those appetites you as a human
being need more what those aren't
accomplishments like that thought was
your problem with dan we had on him was
like dotes it's not that inspiring it's
both me it's they're not accomplishments
like posting a picture you know with a
girl with big tits and you know and at
the beach on vegas or the pool at Vegas
that's and and to his credit the reason
I started following him only I don't
know I don't know why but but to his
credit he knows that and to his credit I
think he's been up front about you know
I think if you spoke to him I don't know
him he would probably say that my next
my next challenge is to figure out how
to make my life fulfilling you and I had
a long conversation about what
accomplishment really means and i was
talking to these guys to evan Killian
and oh before I came in yeah about about
the idea that you can craft your life
into a masterpiece and what I mean by
that this is really important to
somebody who's almost 50 to kind of
share is that what matters and what's
fun and you have now discovered this
Brennan is that real fulfillment comes
from getting very good at something and
more importantly maybe even being
creative or
round that thing sort of sitting down
and brain stores in our world or be but
it can be in anything it can be in a
business it can be in anything where you
are looking at how what's a better way
to do X gotta kick it off with uh with
our boy jason Ellis oh yeah he fought he
fought Shane Carwin in a literal tied
arm behind his back man let's just brush
you Brennan right else may be honest you
know I kidding I mean Jason uh I mean
Jason's my boy I'd never go bad on all
right I think he kind of knew like Jason
when I went on a show that same week
he's like what's the what's gonna happen
yeah of course they expect me get
knocked out like writing like that I'd
live to see another day like I was in
there Shane Carwin it's I I please you
know the fans and stuff like that and
showed him that you know I have the
balls to do it he the one thing about
Jason he even said this he trained his
ass off so he's like I defy you knocked
out least I did the best version of me
in there you know i'm saying so
definitely took some balls long shots he
literally thought he was gonna go in
there and and like when the first two
rounds and thought she wasn't get
frustrated and there's didn't give shane
his right hand I was like dude I'm
telling you he was gonna give Shane his
right hand if if but if he won the first
two rounds a guy let's eat together he
had no idea huh yeah I mean Jay listen
Jason's been in there at wild card you
know with some straight pros and hangs
in there goes like five six rounds with
these monsters men like Jason can box
that's impressive but you know Shane
Collins I change my turned 85 pounds
here oh my god like like chainsaw [ __ ]
he's a truck man he's a monster and
change that the guy you want to do this
with like [ __ ] like I the people sing go
why don't you do it I would never do
that because you wouldn't want to hit
him hey I don't want to be part of that
be I just don't want to do i do I don't
want to have no interesting it wouldn't
make you feel in any way you probably
feel bad if you had to open up on yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't knock jason Ellis
out no matter what even has hit me hard
right shame you lay in one punch he's
gonna he's gonna want to get you back
that's shame James a animal it's but you
did call it you said you were kind of
like I don't like us like Jason this is
a good good I mean call
it's like you know I'm saying anyone
Keely could call it she never box he has
one hand doesn't matter like little even
anyone's like it's a bit but you've
always said that with pros like when i
have i've had friends who trained a lot
and they're actors and I'm like well he
did really well against him inspiring
and you go you're talking about a pro
fighter it doesn't matter what you say
he would get my favorite when people go
he's so small like a yeah I know I know
he is small you know what he would do to
you like it's so it's like sighs like it
usually people just have no idea they
have no idea I have no until you've been
in there with somebody who's really good
when they said he's so small were they
talking about anyone TJ del J Dillashaw
oh gosh Dimitri I'm name anyone the okay
you look at you're like man you're a lot
smaller oh it's hilarious when someone
who's like 63 will say like you know
sober six butter something I thought
would be I go I could kick Demetrius
trots down I do it in my man you have no
[ __ ] idea what you're talking about
oh so it's like you wouldn't saw Daniel
Cormier like I can't believe how short
is mean I get that the polo on yeah like
nothing yeah I get that yeah when the
grace 5 all time he could let beat up
that entire room all it works I [ __ ]
love it so yeah that's why it drives me
nuts when people whose talk about sighs
all the time yeah cuz I was looking at
the size difference between you and him
I mean it's a skill um yes skill and I
was like dancehall skill it's all skill
ausco it's all skill incredible that's
what makes it so great unless you get a
guy who's twice the size of DC and you
had the same skill then you're gonna
have issues here from story it looks
like one FC is kind of going after him
oh don't have that George don't Eric
spice Lee the guy who beat Thiago Santos
couple weeks ago yeah he tweeted that
GSP told me the fight he's most
interested outside of the UFC is Ben
Askren that just just B's obsessed with
wrestling and grappling you know he's a
very high level breast so I get that
George and I will text him after this do
not listen I loved one FCS all great
bulova you go to want to see you
disappear as far as the America that as
North America Canada you gone yeah sign
was one Fc see what happens your career
you got yeah you gotta be a girl you got
to be go to Bellator they have the money
you get revenue of the
the TV deals you give them movies
whatever you want to do man so you try a
coven if UFC stepped up and gave him
like a crazy deal you would say in don't
goes I would sign with you see there is
don't your twisted yeah there's this one
sees the best in the world is the best
word of what they do and the best
fighters and the best fighters if you
wanna be if depends what you want to do
uh when you get a title shot right away
of course yeah yeah yeah but with uh if
the UFC came to agreement and they're
going to give you the necessary money
that under armours pain you know the
sponsors you lose out on and you can go
back and fight for the tire right away
you sign with you sure don't don't ever
get it twisted i know i'm a I can be a
little negative on USC's there's only
one real or junctions UFC but they're
not playing ball with GSP so you go to
Bellator and that's what you'd really
good point they clearly don't know what
they have no no no it's just my fans
scary man again I have no skin in the
game I'm not on this ship anymore I
jumped that ship two years ago when I
retired I've nothing to do with the game
so but as an outsider looking in and
knowing some other details about the
deal and people involved they don't know
what they're doing I just don't know you
got you got it it's tough man yes I
don't have to say the example would be
like if you have an actor so it'd be
like all right you might it's like Tom
Hardy putting you know I'm saying
playing a fighter not a real fighter
right you know I'm saying but you have
him now he's the head of it you know I'm
saying like he's Entertainer man don't
know what he's doing he's staring at
chip that's crazy right it's crazy and
then it but then he got egos with Dana
who's like now we can't pay him that
much money cuz then everyone else gonna
want that money its GSP man yeah he's
generated a lot of income and a lot of
interest mr. friggin he's 35 GSP man not
now you have Rory you think about Rory
vs GSP over in Bellator you got Rory
yeah just be a chill over there now
Benton Henderson it's good man yeah it's
good you got some exciting fighters over
there you got some really athletic
exciting fighters with some just be
cringing drug test GSP is a big one
ladies and gentlemen he's
a member and lead singer of a group
called sugar ray he's Irish he's got all
his hair he's the best listen I he's the
best-looking guy in here is he awesome
guy in here he's an American and his
name is mark McGrath lanes John the
legend oh you guys rat ladies gentleman
tell him you want to fly good how's
thank you I'll give you a beating woman
yes where I get that the most where you
were just talking about happy happy dude
I just say I know I now get I got God
put your arms around ya I gotta do
that's everybody's moment I gotta give
me a moment that may gotta give them
their own that makes me furious well how
about it would you know what you they
own you in that moment you know I way
they deserve it you know fear me if
you're kind of to recognize me and like
look I you call douche dad I'll take
this listen you know the stink of the
90s is going away so there's a whole
freedom for like the vanilla ice is in
me of the world last year I have to come
up with you know it never the
responsibility kind of never goes going
back to music how has the game change
because now you have YouTube yeah you
know everything streaming now there's no
I no one's buying albums no one's going
to bestbuy buying albums so for you guys
to hit at that point which was you know
of miracle in itself yes now I feel like
there's there's easier access to a fan
base but it's so much more competitive
because if Brian I want to start a band
tomorrow we can upload to YouTube yeah
we're going work at all dollars media
we're gonna start a band we just found a
[ __ ] lead singer he's gone oh yeah
yeah I'm your day babe you know you guys
are hot right now not leaving this room
till we [ __ ] we write a song like
I'll get my snake on your train Vita Lee
Valley we're gonna run some people who
is like be regular [ __ ] no no that's
just a given he jumps on people all time
oh hey man [ __ ] tell me give info oh
man looks so terrified what if you were
there to help the monkey lefty jal-0 oh
my god well yeah y'all gonna kill her
you got my stew stupid lord
I couldn't even do that i was just like
it yanked on my ear if he scratched my
phone is it wasn't being nice hey so
terrible buddy hey I bet you're trying
to impress some girl there cuz I know
Brian no I was and you're like what like
oh dude i did a wheel kick for her i was
she before the head [ __ ] yes but a voice
you did I did not then this little
innocent monkey like a blackout oh yeah
I was telling her oh I'm she was older
and I was like well I live in DC right
now am I told my sister is the ultimate
cockblock I'm trying to pick this woman
up she's older a scientist couldn't give
two shits about me first I have to
volunteer that I'm a black belt in
Taekwondo she didn't know like I'm a
blogger and I go yeah I live in DC you
know and my sister goes um he goes to
college there and my dad pays all his
hey dude hey hahaha kills me killed mr.
shoes yeah he doesn't even have a job
when he wants money he calls my dad's
secretary oh by the way he's also paid
for this trip my wheels are and then
that monkey when I try seal the deal dad
I doubled on Trump a whole bunch
thoughts I eat total gentleman to me
never saw him act untoward to anybody
you know um he loves himself there's no
doubt about that he's a trump you see on
TV but I didn't you know to me was a
gentleman like and when I got fired in a
battle of wits against Gary Busey in the
boardroom um it was a TV show lessen
competition uh he brought me his office
the next day didn't have to took a half
hour to talk to me and said hey I
appreciate everything you did you know
you need a recommendation I'm here for
you you know my hotels are well you're
welcome to standard a travel a lot so I
don't bad word to say about him you know
he's 02 02 I think you off I to be
President I'm a sensitive a story yeah
do I pick Hillary is that's all yeah but
so bit behind the scenes and you've
obviously had a discussion you know way
better than both of us or anyone in here
for that matter uh he's like a guy's guy
these guys got you know one thing he did
say Lisa Rinna was sitting there and you
know she just had extra lipstick Flay
did you know he goes at least I'm glad
you got that you took the lip stuff
funny lips you know you look much more
beautiful you're very beautiful but yeah
I'm sure Harry's happier now too
so I think and I ugh like I just you
know was an old school guys at all
Scotty look--yes just bare beings been
handed to him is titled manis millions
of bucks and you know i got like that
get away a lot more sorry she's the way
society is yeah you know and he's dealt
like daddy's little bit got one foot in
that old school madman sort of executive
style you know I was the only thing I
saw was a lie oh Jesus yeah you're let
your contact with him fairly limited or
is it pretty yes it's very limited to me
you see what you see add on junior lot
of alcalá Ivanka's one of those lovely
graceful human beings you'll ever meet
in your life she lights up a room it's
at she's she's easy she's a fur vest and
she she's articulate she's graceful I
mean there was there's she was right
these kids were raised right on i'll get
me worth cause you for all three what's
the worst gig you've ever played wow
[ __ ] I'm start with you yeah it's a good
one we play a gig in Spokane Washington
and 1997 a month before fly broke and we
were with three signed bands one was
called the urge from st. Louis was
called snot from Santa Barbara they are
evident and one was Sugar Ray and nobody
showed up to three signed major label
bands now one person showed up there was
a guy at the bar with the most air
things his mouth or his nose Shh and
then as soon as he left we could play we
played to nobody soma cater say there's
one person there was nobody there nobody
there and then the next show we quit we
go where we're going home the tours is
not working and then a month later fly
was everywhere around the the universe
and elsewhere that was worse kick but
it's also the best gig is all the bands
got had fun and kind of played each
other's Wow yes nobody not one yeah
buddy okay that's so pissed I open forum
I'd open not one yeah yeah not what they
say promoters I have as a comic I have
performed with gusto with gust 0 for 4
people and one person there was one
person I did a half hour for him and he
was from Israel and he was laughing like
this ah
gonzo Comedy Store Tuesday night 12 12
a.m. ki her head I'll I'm killing him I
needed a good yeah i mean i'm giving him
a show like I like I'd be burned with
3,500 people just ain in it he's going
haha he was giving me the mark McGrath
I've widget you got a great hood I was
getting that the whole time one of the
best sets and that's what I was one of
my best game of my best cakes